אם מסובבים כדור סביב ציר אחד ואז סביב ציר אחר זה לא אותו דבר כמו לעשות את שתי הסיבובים בסדר הפוך
היום ב-Qiskit בכיתה נראה מה הקשר של הכדור הזה למחשבים קוונטיים ולאחד העקרונות הכי מפורסמים
של מכניקת הקוונטים עקרון אי הוודאות
ברוכים הבאים ל-Qiskit בכיתה סדרת וידאו שבה אנחנו מפרקים מושג בסיסי שאתם עשויים
להיתקל בו בקורס שקשור למחשוב קוונטי כל סרטון מלווה במודול אינטראקטיבי שמקושר
בתיאור למטה אז תבדקו את זה היום אנחנו מדברים על עקרון אי הוודאות של הייזנברג אם
שמעתם על זה בעבר אולי גם שמעתם את הבדיחה הישנה על הייזנברג יום אחד הוא נעצר בזמן נהיגה והשוטר שאל אותו האם אתה
יודע כמה מהר נסעת הייזנברג ענה לא אבל אני יודע בדיוק איפה אני נמצא זה בערך
עקרון אי הוודאות של הייזנברג בקצרה אי אפשר לדעת בו זמנית את המיקום והתנע של חלקיק
בדיוק מושלם בדרך כלל כותבים את זה ככה דלתא x כפול דלתא p גדול מ
או שווה ל h חלקי 2 כאשר דלתא X ודלתא P הם
אי הוודאויות במיקום ובתנע ו-H הוא קבוע בסיסי זעיר במכניקת הקוונטים
הייזנברג הגיע לאי שוויון הזה עוד ב-1927 כשהוא דמיין איך למדוד את המיקום של אלקטרון אם
מקפיצים פוטון ממנו כדי לראות איפה הוא הפוטון הזה בהכרח יבעט באלקטרון וישבש את
התנע שלו זה לא רק אמירה על כך שמדידות משבשות מערכת זה אומר לנו שיש גבולות בסיסיים
לכמה שאנחנו יכולים ללמוד על הטבע זו דוגמה אחת לעקרון רחב יותר שנקרא משלימות שאומר
שהיבטים מסוימים של הטבע אינם תואמים זה את זה ולא ניתן לצפות בהם
בו זמנית למשל עצמים קוונטיים לפעמים מתנהגים כמו חלקיקים ולפעמים כמו גלים
אבל אי אפשר לצפות בשתי ההתנהגויות בו זמנית יחס המיקום והתנע של הייזנברג כיסה רק אחד מ
הרבה סטים של תכונות משלימות אי הוודאות המובנית הזו קשורה לאופן שבו אנחנו רואים תכונות כמו
מיקום ותנע במכניקת הקוונטים במקום לחשוב על X ו-P כמשתנים או תכונות מובנות
שלכל חלקיק יש במכניקת הקוונטים מיקום ותנע הם אופרטורים הם לא תכונות של
מערכת אלא דברים שאפשר לעשות למערכת ללמוד על המיקום של חלקיק עכשיו דורש ממך לבצע
פעולה על המערכת ולבצע מדידה הפעולה הזו עלולה להשפיע על התוצאה של פעולות
עוקבות אחרות בתור אנלוגיה חשבו על חתיכת עץ יבש יש לה הרבה תכונות כמו
מיקום גודל צורה יש לה גם את התכונה של להיות בת-שריפה ובת-ציפה במים אם העץ הזה היה עצם
קוונטי אלה לא היו תכונות שאפשר פשוט לדעת מראש במקום זה אנחנו אומרים שהן
נצפיות דברים שאפשר ללמוד על המערכת אם מבצעים עליה פעולה כלשהי אז צריך להפעיל אופרטורים של בת-
שריפה או בת-ציפה מה שידרוש בפועל לנסות לשרוף את העץ או לשים אותו
במים כדי לראות אם הוא צף עכשיו התוצאה של כל אחד מהאופרטורים האלה תלויה בסדר שמפעילים אותם אם
בודקים קודם בת-שריפה העץ יישרף לאפר ולא תוכלו לבדוק אם הוא צף אבל אם בודקים
בת-ציפה קודם אז הוא יהיה רטוב מדי כדי לשרוף אנחנו אומרים שאופרטורי הבת-שריפה
והבת-ציפה לא מתחלפים סדר הפעולות חשוב זה מוביל לגבול בסיסי
על כמה טוב אפשר לדעת את שתי הנצפיות האלה לגבי חתיכת העץ מכיוון שאי אפשר לומר בוודאות אם היא
בת-שריפה או בת-ציפה בלי לדעת את ההקשר של המדידה כמובן שעם חתיכת עץ אמיתית אפשר
לחתוך אותה לשניים ולבדוק את שתי התכונות בו זמנית אבל אי אפשר לעשות שום דבר כזה עם חלקיק קוונטי
האנלוגיה לעץ היא בדיוק זה אנלוגיה אי ודאות זה דבר קוונטי ייחודי X ו-P גם לא מתחלפים
והתכונה הזו של אי-חילופיות היא מה שמוביל לעקרון אי הוודאות של הייזנברג באופן כללי כל שני אופרטורים
שלא מתחלפים יהיה להם עקרון אי ודאות משלהם הצורה הכללית של עקרון אי הוודאות אפשר
לכתוב ככה דלתא a כפול דלתא
B גדול מ או שווה ל
12 כפול a ו-b כאשר
הסוגריים האלה נקראים
קומוטטור וזה שווה להפרש בין להפעיל קודם a ואז
B ולהפעיל קודם B ואז a הסוגריים הזוויתיים
האלה מסמנים שלוקחים מה שנקרא ערך הציפייה של מה שבפנים בעצם אם עושים את אותה
מדידה הרבה הרבה פעמים ערך הציפייה הוא הממוצע של כל המדידות האלה היום אנחנו
הולכים באמת לבדוק ולאמת את עקרון אי הוודאות הזה על מחשב קוונטי של IBM נסתכל על שלוש
נצפיות שונות של qubit נראה שהאופרטורים שלהן לא מתחלפים ואז לבסוף נוכל להוכיח שעקרון
אי הוודאות מתקיים עבור הנצפיות האלה של ה-qubit קודם כל הערה קצרה על דרך שימושית לדמיין את המצב הקוונטי
של qubit אפשר לייצג אותו כווקטור שמצביע למקום כלשהו על כדור שנקרא כדור בלוך כיסיתי
את זה בסרטון קודם שמקושר בתיאור אבל אתן לכם סיכום קצר גם פה הנה
כדור בלוך כל וקטור מתואר על ידי שני זוויות תטא ופי
המצב אפס הוא בקוטב הצפוני והמצב אחד הוא בקוטב הדרומי וסופרפוזיציה שווה של 0 ו-1 נמצאת
איפשהו לאורך קו המשווה כאשר פי שווה לפאזה היחסית בין שני החלקים של
הסופרפוזיציה אז המצב הזה כאן יהיה שווה
ל-1 חלקי שורש 2 כפול 0 ועוד e בחזקת i כפול 1 כאשר i זו
הפאזה כשמודדים נצפית של ה-qubit התוצאה היא תמיד אחת משתי אפשרויות שמתאימות לשני
המצבים האפשריים של ה-qubit בניסוי שאנחנו עומדים לעשות נסתכל על שלוש נצפיות ועל
האופרטורים המתאימים שלהן X Y ו-Z כשמודדים כל אחת מהנצפיות האלה מקבלים או פלוס אחד או
מינוס אחד עם הסתברות לכל אחד שתלויה בזווית בין הוקטור של ה-qubit על כדור בלוך לבין
ציר המדידה כפי שאפשר לצפות Z מודד לאורך ציר Z ו-X לאורך X
ו-Y לאורך Y עכשיו זכרו שאנחנו מדברים על נצפיות כי עם מערכת
קוונטית אי אפשר יותר פשוט לדעת דברים על המערכת בלי למדוד אותם
ולכל נצפית יש פעולה מתאימה כי מדידות דורשות פעולות אולי זה לא מובן מאליו אבל
מסתבר שהפעולות שנקראות אופרטורים שמתאימות לכל אחת מהנצפיות האלה X Y ו-Z הן
סיבובים של פאי סביב הצירים המתאימים שלהן אז X זה סיבוב סביב X ו-Y
סביב Y ו-Z סביב Z אז כדי לראות אם האופרטורים האלה מתחלפים או לא אפשר לבדוק אם סיבובים
על כדור מתחלפים אם כן עקרון אי הוודאות לא יחול ונוכל לדעת X Y ו-Z של qubit
בדיוק מושלם אם הם לא מתחלפים אז נוכל למצוא יחס אי ודאות חדש עבור ה-qubit עקבו
אחרי הנקודה על הכדור הזה כשאני מסובב קודם סביב X ואז סביב Y היא מגיעה
לפה עכשיו בואו ננסה בסדר הפוך אז אני מסובב קודם סביב Y ואז
סביב X היא מגיעה לפה אז הם בהחלט לא מתחלפים זה אומר
שאי אפשר לדעת בו זמנית את ערכי X Y ו-Z המדויקים של qubit יהיה לנו יחס
אי ודאות נדלג על הפרטים כאן אבל בסוף מגיעים לשלושה יחסי אי ודאות
שונים אז יש לנו דלתא x כפול דלתא Y
גדול מ או שווה ל-Z דלתא Y דלתא Z גדול מ או
שווה ל-X ודלתא Z דלתא X גדול מ או שווה
ל-Y אז המכפלה של כל שתיים מאי הוודאויות האלה תמיד גדולה מ או
שווה לערך הציפייה של הנצפית השלישית בואו נשתמש ב-Qiskit כדי לראות מה
קורה כשמנסים למדוד גם Z וגם X של המצב אפס מדידת Z זה קל זה מה שנקרא הבסיס הסטנדרטי
של המחשב הקוונטי מדידות תמיד לאורך Z כברירת מחדל אבל כדי למדוד X צריך לבצע משהו שנקרא
החלפת בסיס בעצם סיבוב כדור בלוך כך ש-X מצביע עכשיו למעלה לאן ש-Z הצביע כדי לעשות את זה
משתמשים ב-Hadamard gate אז ה-circuit הקוונטי המלא ייראה ככה מודדים ב-Z מפעילים את ה-Hadamard
ואז מודדים ב-X אם משתמשים ב-Qiskit Primitive Sampler כדי להריץ את הניסוי הזה הרבה פעמים מגיעים
להיסטוגרמה של תוצאות מדידה שנראית ככה עבור מדידת
Z וככה עבור המדידה ב-X אז כפי שאפשר לראות מדדנו את
ה-qubit במצב אפס לאורך Z עם כמעט 100% ודאות אבל
לאורך X לא ידענו כמעט כלום על מצב ה-qubit הוא נמדד כאפס או אחד עם הסתברות
שווה כלומר אי הוודאות שלנו ב-X היתה גדולה ככל שאפשר זה נותן לנו
קצת תחושה של הפשרה הזו בין אי הוודאויות אבל אפשר לעשות קצת יותר טוב על המחשב הקוונטי שלנו אפשר להשתמש
ב-Qiskit Primitive שנקרא estimator כדי למצוא את ערכי הציפייה של הנצפיות שלנו X Y ו-Z ואת
אי הוודאות בכל אחת בואו ננסה את זה עבור המצב שמצביע בכיוון פלוס X על כדור בלוך נשתמש ב-estimator
כדי לחשב את אי הוודאויות ב-X וב-Z עבור המצב הזה ואת ערך הציפייה של
Y עם המצב הזה מקבלים את התוצאה הזו מ-Qiskit כשלוקחים את המכפלה של שתי
אי הוודאויות ב-X וב-Y רואים שכמצופה היא גדולה מהערך
המוחלט של ערך הציפייה של Y אבל זה היה רק עבור מצב אחד ספציפי אנחנו רוצים לוודא שאי השוויון הזה
מתקיים עבור כל מצבי ה-qubit אז בואו נשתמש ב-estimator שוב אבל הפעם נבקש ממנו לסרוק דרך ערכי
פרמטר ולמצוא את ערכי הציפייה בכל ערך פרמטר בודד שניתן לו כאן הפרמטר שאנחנו רוצים
לסרוק הוא הזווית תטא על כדור בלוך כך שנבדוק את אי השוויון עבור כל מצבי ה-qubit שנמצאים על
הקשת הזו שחוצה את מישור XZ כשעושים את זה מקבלים גרף כפונקציה של הזווית תטא העקומה
האדומה היא מכפלת שתי אי הוודאויות והעקומה הכתומה היא ערך הציפייה של Y כמצופה
מכפלת אי הוודאויות ב-X וב-Z הרבה יותר גבוהה מערך הציפייה של Y אבל זה לא היה
קשה מדי לקיים את אי השוויון כי ערך הציפייה של Y היה כל כך נמוך הוא היה אפס עבור כל המצבים על
הקשת הזו בואו נעשה סריקה דומה דרך ערכי תטא אבל במקום לסרוק במישור XZ נקבע פי שווה לפאי חלקי
4 כך שאנחנו מסתכלים על מצבי ה-qubit שנמצאים על קשת אחרת על הכדור כאן רואים שאי השוויון
נבדק קצת יותר מכיוון שהעקומה הכתומה והאדומה קרובות יותר אבל האדומה תמיד מעל הכתומה
ועקרון אי הוודאות עדיין מתקיים עוד לא בדקנו את כל המצבים אבל מקווה שאתם מתחילים לתפוס
את הרעיון יש אי-ידיעה מובנית לגבי כל שני היבטים משלימים של מערכת
קוונטית כולל ה-qubit הזה שהשתמשנו בו עקרון אי הוודאות מכריח אותנו להתמודד עם העובדה שלא משנה
כמה נתאמץ לא משנה כמה חכמות המדידות שלנו לעולם לא נדע הכל בדיוק מושלם
אין דרך לעקוף את זה באמת אם אתם לא מאמינים לי או אפילו אם כן אני מאתגר אתכם לכו תבדקו את המודול
שמקושר בתיאור ותנסו לנצח את עקרון אי הוודאות תודה שצפיתם ונתראה בפעם הבאה